on ne changera pas le monde en se
conformant aux règles mais le monde doit
changer
qu'est-ce que tu sois prêt à risquer
pour ton idéal à la liberté à la liberté
tes amis
pour l'amour service
est-ce que 8,4
je ne comprends
ce cas
si tu arrives en a rien à [ __ ] du
tennis rien à [ __ ] de moi y'a rien qui
t'intéresse dans la tremblade site a la
trouille d'y aller seul on peut sauter
tous les deux
j'ai plus peur de rien et s'apprêterait
à la révolution pour mon paquet coupé
coeur et le lui offrir sur un plateau
qu'est ce qui compte le plus c'est les
yeux tes convictions politiques ou ta
jolie petite frimousse tenais pour
vibrant tôt
[Musique]
quel risque est ce que tu as osé prendre
pour défendre des convictions un corner
est ce que vous pouvez avoir la
conscience tranquille
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]